my biggest deficit was that I didn't
have any diplomatic experience but my
biggest Advantage was that I didn't have
any diplomatic experience so I came in
and I give one example in here where I'm
meeting with the ruler of the UAE who's
uh thought to be the most strategic
thinker in the region he's somebody's
been there a while he just became the
president of the country and he's a guy
Muhammad bin Zayed who's a who's really
a giant and I'm meeting with him
after about six months and I take him
through some of the thoughts as to how
one approach it and I really was asking
him a ton of questions and he says I
think you're going to make peace here so
why do you say that
it says well the U.S usually sends one
of three types of people to see me the
first types are people who come and fall
asleep in meetings as the second are
people who come and they basically read
me talking points and have no ability to
have a a conversation the third are
senior level people who come and
basically try to convince me to do
things that are against my interests he
says you're the first person who's ever
come to see me from the U.S who's asking
questions
thank you
all right let's jump over to the to the
peace process so now things are
happening you're a couple years in you
were working on this from day one
basically really was it from day one
like you said this is going to be
something I'm gonna get on did he want
you on that was this something that you
just brought to him so
um
the way I found out about it was I get a
call from the woman who did uh public
relations for our real estate business
and at the time ivank and I were still
thinking will we go to Washington or not
and she calls and says the New York
Times just called and said you and
Ivanka decided to go to Washington that
you're working on Middle East peace I
said well that's not true I said that we
have made a decision he says well their
source is your father-in-law I said okay
so he went there for I guess an
editorial board meeting and they asked
him he saw Jared's great he's going to
come and he's going to work on middle oh
that's hilarious I don't know if you
meant it or not but you know the next
day you're like who is Jared Kushner
what the hell does he know about the
Middle East they were right I didn't
know anything but maybe it was the last
time they were right and um but then you
know after the first couple months I
said okay well this is something I was
tasked with let me let me start
exploring so you know Jason Greenblatt
came in with me and Avi Berkowitz and we
started
um we started just researching what had
been done before us and what I did in
the first year was I I just tried to
understand everyone's perspective on the
files so my biggest deficit was that I
didn't have any diplomatic experience
but my biggest Advantage was that I
didn't have any diplomatic experience so
I came in and I give one example in here
where I'm meeting with the ruler of the
UAE who's uh thought to be the most
strategic thinker in the region he's
somebody who's been there a while he
just became the president of the country
and he's a guy Mohammed bin Zayed who's
a who's really a giant and I'm meeting
with him
after about six months and I take him
through some of the thoughts as to how
one approach it and I really was asking
him a ton of questions and he says I
think you're going to make peace here so
why do you say that
he says well the U.S usually sends one
of three types of people to see me
the first types are people who come and
fall asleep in meetings as the second
are people who come and they basically
read me talking points and have no
ability to have a a conversation the
third are senior level people who come
and basically try to convince me to do
things that are against my interests he
says you're the first person who's ever
come to see me from the U.S who's asking
questions
and my fundamental question was very
simple which is the US has a ton of
power
um
what would you do if you were us right
like what's the end State that's
achievable here and what levers would
you play with if you or us in order to
try to achieve that end State and it
took them a couple times of me asking
that question to actually understand
that I was seeking like a an honest
feedback on the question but that was
how I started with everyone trying to
understand get their point of view on
what needed to be done knowing that
American foreign policy and this is not
a knock on Democrats knock on Democrats
and Republicans basically screwed up the
entire Middle East if you take it from
you know allowing even just from you
know the fall of the Shah and Iran to
you know the the the the revolution in
79 and then you go into obviously the
allowing Al Qaeda to have Harbor and and
then the attacks on on the US and
getting us into a war in Iraq and a war
in Afghanistan and then you have
disbanding the Army and then it just it
goes on and on and on then you know you
have uh Isis has a caliphate the size of
Ohio they're beheading journalists
they're uh they're killing Christians uh
they're they're you know you have uh
them radicalizing people online the San
Bernardino shooting the the Pulse
Nightclub shooting uh Syria is in a
civil war half a million people are
killed I mean U.S policy in that region
for decades was absolutely awful and
part of me I guess maybe trouble saying
can't get any worse so give Jared a try
right um but we thought about it in a
different way and really worked hard and
I write about kind of my journey trying
to understand it for what it was at the
time instead of being romanced by the
old Notions and then the more I would
talk to the people who'd done it they
would explain well this is what you have
to look at this you have to it's like
that makes absolutely no sense to me and
I was like okay well if I'm gonna fail
at least I'll fail in an original way
and doing something that I think is
logical and I was creamed I mean the New
York Times would tell me uh all the
experts you know on CNN they would write
articles you know saying that everything
I was doing was wrong and stupid and
Reckless and gonna cause Wars well even
as the the announcements were coming out
as the deals were coming out they were
saying why these are bad deals and it's
like oh they weren't good I thought that
we all wanted Middle East peace wasn't
that one thing there's a short list of
things we all agree on that used to be
one thing that we all kind of want so
did you find that a lot of the countries
actually were quite willing once once
you made that initial sort of once you
flip the script on them in essence so in
some ways the entrenchment there was
just as bad as the entrenchment home
right so you think about all these these
critics
and what you have in Washington is like
this this class of people who are
basically careerists you know you know
going in and out of Washington and then
you have the same people who are writing
about them or from the think tanks or or
the the media and they're also you know
so it's like the same class I believe
this is what we call the swamp and
they're they're all vested in not being
proven wrong so they'd rather you also
fail than you be proven right and do it
and the whole notion of the Trump
presidency was bringing people who are
Outsiders to Washington who are results
driven you know again politicians are
about process and and talking points uh
businessmen are about results and so we
come in with a fundamentally different
approach and and that's the theme in my
book that happens time and time again
right there's two basic cross currents
in the book one is
what it was like to be under endless
attack from you know Russia
investigation and impeachment about
trying to you know look into corruption
in Ukraine all the media attacks and
that that's one car and I call that the
waves and then you have kind of under
the water where it's nice and calm which
is how did all these policies get done
right how do we get trade deals done how
do we get peace deals done how do we get
deals with Congress done we have
Criminal Justice Reform done
um and so I really try to put those two
things together but that that that that
complacency was the same thing I found
in the Middle East in the sense that
everyone
thought that there were limitations to
what they could do and what I found is
like all these barriers are usually in
people's minds and
and in the region everyone thought it
was fixed and that if there were certain
things you did it was just unsolvable
and you had to go and solve it the same
way that people before I tried to solve
it and fail or else it's gonna be world
war three and I take people through
again I take them into the situation
room and and really try to give them
the intensity of was like to make some
of the first decisions right so Trump
making the decision to move the embassy
to Jerusalem his secretary of state was
against it Secretary of Defense was
against it the Intel Community comes out
with assessments saying that if he does
it it could be world war three yeah and
the world's going to explode and again
Trump even though every president for
what had said they were going to do it
but then they all got scared Away by the
conventional thinking that happened and
what Trump did again a businessman
you think about okay that's a risk how
do I assess the risk and then how do I
mitigate the risk and I talk about how
we assess the risk how we mitigated the
risk and how we pushed forward to do it
and at the end of the day at that point
he'd gotten closer with the Arab
countries he said look you can't cherry
pick your relationship with America
Iran's your biggest threat I'm going to
work with you on that because I agree
with you on that right that's in our
common interests but don't mess around
on the things that I want to do Israel
is a sovereign country they have the
right to determine their capital and
America's a sovereign country and we
have the right to recognize the decision
of another sovereign country and that's
what I'm doing okay and I'm not going to
ask your opinion and again it was very
very intense because people showed the
Trump makes a decision and I really give
some funny stories about kind of the
back and forth and the high stakes of it
but he makes a decision
and then we worked hard to mitigate and
then what happens is the next morning
the sun rises and the next evening the
sun sets and the world moves on same
thing with getting out of the Iran deal
people warned him that if you do this
you're gonna have world war three
everything's gonna blow up he makes a
decision the next morning the sun rises
next evening the sun sets and he figured
out ways to maneuver and so all of a
sudden everything that seems so fixed to
people
all of a sudden was becoming a little
bit more uh of of of of of a fluid
situation if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell